c'était dans ces tranchées autour de
kiev ces soldats du craignent un garde
l'oeil sur la ligne de front vigilant à
une éventuelle attaque malgré les
engagements pris par la russie de
réduire son offensive autour de la
capitale une avancée substantielle sur
le papier lors des négociations entre
l'ukraine et la russie hier
moi je donne à ces ratés nous pouvons
dire que les signaux que nous entendons
des négociations sont positifs mais ces
signaux ne couvre pas encore le bruit
des explosions de russie
des obus qui continue pourtant de tomber
sur le crème comme cette nuit à carson
ou tchernihiv
la communauté internationale dit
attendre des actes
il est trop tôt pour dire quelle est la
destination
quel est le but final où ses troupes
russes vont aller à long terme
plutôt qu'un retrait nous pensons qu'il
s'agit probablement d'un
repositionnement des troupes pour être
utilisé ailleurs
prudents pour l'occident alors que kiev
est un pas vers moscou et propose ird
adopter un statut de neutralité
l'ukraine renoncerait à intégrer l'otan
à accueillir des bases militaires
étrangères et à détenir l'armé nucléaire
en échange elle réclame la protection en
cas d' attaques de plusieurs pays les
états unis la chine la france le royaume
uni mais aussi la turquie l'allemagne
israël et la pologne qui elle souhaite
aussi pouvoir adhérer à l'union
européenne et propose que les
territoires contrôlés par les
séparatistes pro russes soient
temporairement exclus des discussions la
balle est désormais dans le camp de
vladimir pitch